but uh you mentioned corey bush there's
one other person who uh uh also helped
lead the charge for these riots and i
want to bring this up have a question
about this uh that person obviously was
kamala harris yes she tweeted out the
link to donate to rioters
who
i mean some of these people i'm not
gonna list their crimes but there's some
very serious crimes some of these
writers who had committed and she just
blanket says we're gonna we're gonna you
know raise money to bail them out
she said the texas house democrats
protest that's what she calls it a
protest shows extraordinary courage so
for those that are just tuning in this
is basically the democrats in texas are
illegally blocking a vote by fleeing the
state in private jets to where dc i
think right yeah and kamala harris i
wonder if there's like a is it is it
illegal to encourage someone to commit a
crime is it you know am i am i going too
far by her saying it's just courage did
she actually encourage them to do it
well that's we call that being an
accessory
and people go to jail for being an
accessory but remember that the texas
democrats they did that in the final
days of our regular session at the end
of may and they took a trip up here to
washington dc they were met by the vice
president and she called them courageous
and all of these things so this has
already been in the books this was
cooked up you know we went into a
special session last week thursday and
for whatever reason our speaker of the
house down there in in texas put the
house on recess and next thing you know
yeah they're on recess they're up here
playing around
in washington d.c
you know i feel like when you get to the
point where the political parties are
engaging in
voting
instead of policy like so so the goal of
the democrats now is to affect how the
vote happens
yeah that's that's like the last barrier
to the system falling apart because it's
one thing when you have everyone saying
okay we agree these are the rules now
let's play the game yeah now you've got
you're at the point where you're you're
you're you know in the fourth quarter
another coach is saying we're going to
change the rules that rule doesn't count
we got to change everybody come here
we're changing the rules we all agree
it's like no no something's up if they
can't defend themselves on policy and
they're now saying we need to change the
voting rules
that sounds like they've got an argument
to make that sounds like how you lose a
country and when you allow them to take
such petulant actions let's just put it
this way
if republicans were to do this exact
same thing what would be the number one
story on ms lsd
cnn nbc uh what would be the number one
it is the story republican voter
suppression across the country yeah but
that's how they flip it right just the
same as when ginsaki comes out and says
republicans want to defund the police
these guys that was a good one yeah but
these guys are masterful
in how they can manipulate language i
mean all of a sudden they have redefined
what infrastructure is yeah you know and
and so what we've got to do we've got to
get better with that we we've got to
have that little strategic uh you know
cell that sits down and thinks about
where they're going to go and how do we
block it we got to talk about freedom
the word the definition what does it
mean because it's an anti-government
slogan it has apparently now yeah
screaming freedom in cuba's
anti-government uh it is but so we gotta
define freedom what is freedom i don't
have the freedom to go next door and rip
food out of the guys refrigerator i
don't have the freedom to throw you guys
against the wall i don't have freedom in
that sense we have created restrictions
for a society in which we gain certain
types of freedom and so voter
restriction in a lot of ways enhances
freedom because it it creates a
restrictive system that works better
than just a throw it against the wall
and see what sticks type of anarchy
freedom where well let's let's really do
let's put it this way um to help clarify
your point
if you had uh um an electrical current
go into water those electrons are just
free to mill about yes you're not going
to solve any equations with it but if
you restrict the flow of those electrons
you can solve complex equations
computers constrict the flow they
restrict and so i think about this
voting stuff and restriction is is a
false framing they're trying to make it
seem like republicans are trying to take
away people's rights when in actuality
it's about securing the process which
guarantees your rights so that someone
can't come in and steal it for every for
every uh
mis un unmatched signature for every
ballot that should have been rejected
because it was late or whatever that
comes in that negates your your due
diligence the hard work you did to abide
by the rules absolutely but the thing is
that let's put it in a historical
context if we want to talk about voting
uh who has always been the party that
was against voting rights who's always
been the party that was about voting
suppression okay if i remember right the
14th amendment that was republicans you
know and and that was to give blacks
recently freed slaves which is the
reason why the republican party was
founded 13th amendment which the
democrats voted against they also voted
against the 14th amendment they've taken
that equal protection under the law
clause and they perverted it the
democrats were the ones that came up
with jim crow so i really do find it
kind of laughable when you know
everyone's saying jim crow 2.0 well you
guys should know about jim crow because
you started or you talk about the
literacy tests and the poll taxes when
you talk about the ku klux klan why was
the ku klux klan founded the ku klux
klan was founded for voter suppression
to keep blacks from being able to go out
and vote the same type of blacks that
founded the republican party of texas
and those gentlemen who became some
early pioneers and so that's what we
have to start doing is saying that you
know you guys have always been on the
side of this historically when you want
to talk about systemic racism it's you
guys oh they would know i love that i
love how they push the uh the parties
switched line
it's it's it's amazing to me that you
have people who don't read the news
don't read history how do you read
headlines they write headlines i know a
lot of people from chicago people have
known my whole life and they tweet
things like i'll be talking to them and
they'll say yeah well the party switch
and i go when
well it was like you know like a couple
decades ago like the republicans decided
to be democrats and i was like
why
you know what no no no no
they don't have an answer i mean
certainly there are people who have come
up with answers but it's remarkable to
me that by simply telling someone this
they go got it and they have no idea
what it means they have no idea about
the history or the arguments they just
go along with it and that's what they
throw at you when you drop it you say
you're close to west virginia robert
byrd senator from west virginia
was always a democrat he was also a
grand wizard in the ku klux klan and
he's the exact same guy that who
eulogized him at his funeral joe biden
yep and there's the same joe biden who
referred to black men as predators now
when joe biden's standing there in tulsa
oklahoma and he's talking about the
riots that were there and the murdering
of blacks and the destruction of black
wall street he kind of missed this
little great historical anecdote that it
was the democrats who did that
or when you tried to take you know uh
juneteenth which is the day that blacks
found out that they were free
down in texas in 1865 and he tries to
say that this is an independent state
well you know they found out that they
were free because of a republican
president and republicans and what they
did and the emancipation proclamation
that was signed by abraham lincoln not
because of democrats and so they're
trying to steal history and you you're
right they just put out the sound bank
and so yes the party switch and people
just say okay and the more you say that
the more you say that people start to
believe it but when you anecdotally look
at think about this tim the longest
filibuster in u.s senate
history senate democrats against the
1964 civil rights act and they say that
that was around the time the democrats
started switching but i i'd like to play
just a little a little historical game
of walking through a brief a brief time
through history starting with what you
just said democrats filibustering civil
rights okay
from then
where was it where we were having these
police brutality problems and still to
this day the the the left says their
police brutality problems
well it's new york it's la it's chicago
um who runs those cities yeah they're
not run by republicans uh you look at
redlining and blockbusting where were
those policies implemented why that was
chicago i'm sorry i thought chicago's
been democrat since like what the 20s
the greatest amount of failure
is in all of these democrat cities the
greatest amount of crime even though
they try to say republicans defunded
police the greatest amount of black on
black
killing
is in cities that are run by democrats
but yeah i have yet to see you know miss
patrice colors of you know black lives
matter the about marxist it has three
multi-million dollar properties i barely
have a house you know just in like 450
000 but yet i've never seen her go to
chicago detroit uh atlanta dc
philadelphia or any of these places i
got to correct you though i think
actually she has five houses oh
but but they're not they're not same but
they're only like half a million each
and one of them is over a million i
could be wrong i think it's five okay i
know there's three that i thought three
were multi-million maybe the other two
kind of bring the value down i think
what happened was people reported she
had a multi-million dollar house empire
okay but i'm pretty sure a lot of them
are like half a million but but i
thought marxists were all about you know
wealth redistribution and you thought
right spread you know how many people
live in that house i mean shouldn't you
have like whole families living in the
house with it you know just do as i say
not as i we there was a story a while
ago we looked up the data washington
post ran the data the
crime per capita uh and the crime by
population and the funny thing is
when you look at crime by general
population it's like number one is new
york but sure it's not really fair
to look at the top 10 cities and say who
has the most crime aha new york well
yeah new york's got a massive population
just by we look at per capita and the
funny thing is per capita you actually
have to remove
the some republican cities or at the
time republican
mayors because it's all democrats and so
the left's response to this as well
democrats tend to run bigger cities and
i'm like that doesn't mean anything
why do they tend to run bigger cities i
don't know but i'll tell you this if i i
can grow up in chicago and you've got
democrats running it for generations and
they've not solved these problems of
racism and blockbusting and redlining
and segregation
when will you be like we need to stop
voting for these people
because remember that movie shawshank
redemption oh yeah great love it
remember when uh brooks you know he had
been there in the institution for so
long then finally he got to be free
but when they let him out of the
institution he was working at the
grocery store he just could not deal
with it because
he had become an institutional man yeah
and so i think that you have gotten this
institutional mentality of victimhood
that there are some people that have
become so comfortable with section 8
housing so comfortable with the drugs
and the gangs so comfortable with
waiting for the check to come down you
know you start to look at a lot of the
uh fast food restaurants and places like
that they're suffering because people
are getting paid to stay at home and not
work i think that we have this
dependency cycle that is happening and
when you read uh alexander frazier
titlers his you know democracy kind of
exists as a permanent form of government
you read that cycle the cycle
starts with dependence but then as you
go through it you end up coming right
back to dependence and i think that is
what is happening and one of the
critical points is that you get that
apathy
and and and that's what we see happening
here in the united states of america
where people just comfortable
they're complacent in being a victim and
and that's what i you know yesterday i
opened up cpac on on sunday
and i said we got this choice to either
be victors or be victims and what
conservatism what america was founded on
was the individual is a victor
you know you know um
one thing i think makes everything a bit
easier is now that the democrats have
started admitting they're all racists
and white supremacists so you have
people like robin d'angelo and you get
these tick-tock videos where these are
all progressive ultra woke people flat
out saying they're racists and white
supremacists and i'm like thank you for
admitting it we've long suspected it but
i think you know as many people have
pointed out it's like the soft bigotry
of low expectations absolutely or i
think it's uh as carl benjamin calls it
white supremacists with guilty
consciences well you know shelby steele
wrote the book white guilt and all you
folks out there if you haven't read
shelby steele's book white guilt you
should read it and that's how i got to
tell you white folks get hoodwinked
y'all getting hoodwinked man i mean
someone coming up to you and says you're
a white supremacist racist you're just
like yeah get out of here i mean stop
this because but yeah oh please don't
call me that i'll do whatever you want
here's here's you know i'm a corporate
ceo here's 10 million dollars black
lives matter don't talk to me like well
they don't want to break through their
window they don't want to fire well you
know what uh that's why we had a second
amendment you throw a break through my
window something's going to happen you
know also we had yunmi park on the show
she's a north korean she escaped north
korea basically was that the one to talk
to the school board meeting here no no
that was uh
okay well i don't know if she talked
here but she's the one fighting in
schools yeah janmi was a north korean
defector and she she was saying how
freedom is terrifying hard and scary and
she almost went back to north korea when
she had finally received freedom for the
first time because she didn't know what
to make she didn't want to make the
wrong decision and she was so used to
being told what to do so i think these
people that are institutionalized
have a similar life experience where you
know
the opportunity of freedom is it could
you could you could destroy it all you
got to grab it they will they will vote
to maintain those institutions yes and
the democrats i think are trying to
not necessarily i don't think it's as
overt but i think it's a pressure
they're applying a certain pressure so
that in a long enough amount of time
they will generate more
institutionalized voters so i think
what's interesting is there's long been
this trope that democrats want
hispanic voters
uh and they're gonna give they're gonna
bring illegal immigrants because they
want to give them uh you know they're
gonna give them a path of citizenship
the interesting thing is that when you
see in south texas how the hispanic area
is actually voter republican
we've done an incredible job of flicking
flipping the rio grande valley for the
first time in 36 years we have a
republican mayor down in the rio grande
valley we have a 19 year old city
council member roman garcia in kerrville
texas but you just brought up a great
point and this you know i'm not really
smart the army teaches you to carry
three by five cars well you know that is
smarter back too but i want to share
this quote with you all and with the
artist the uncontested absurdities of
today
are the accepted slogans of tomorrow
they come to be accepted by degrees by
dent of constant pressure on one side
and constant retreat on the other until
one day when they are suddenly declared
to be the countries country's official
ideology
you know um iran
it's brilliant it is it is brilliant
because i tweeted about this today
there's a video um that i saw cassandra
fairbanks tweeted in response to some
video it was one of the most absurd
things i've ever seen a guy takes a
coffee maker and he pours i saw that he
pours lemonade in the back he puts
broccoli where the coffee's supposed to
go and he puts a salmon fillet in the
coffee uh uh picture or whatever
and then he turns it on he says this is
totally legit the lemonade will steam
the broccoli and then cook the salmon in
seven minutes
the video is absurd absolutely absurd
there's other videos where a woman is
pouring nachos all over her counter and
it's a disgusting mess you do the same
thing with spaghetti there's videos
where people throw burgers and fries in
the blender and then and then freeze it
and make patties out of it it is
nonsense content meant to shock people
to get shares you see the guy pouring
lemonade on salmon in a coffee maker and
he says sunny d and you're like that's
disgusting i need to show my friends how
disgusting this is here's a problem
little kids they're going to see that
and they're not going to know that it's
meant to manipulate you yeah because
they're going to see a very serious
looking men very seriously saying watch
me cook salmon this way they're going to
grow up with that and then when they're
older they're going to be steam taking a
steam iron and ironing their eggo waffle
while filming themselves with an animal
face filter and it'll just be it'll be
pure insanity because they you know
we're older we understand you don't cook
it's not convenient to cook salmon in a
coffee maker that's stupid yeah but
these kids don't know that now check
this out
here's where it gets a bit more um
damning
in the at the end of the 2000s something
most of you who listen to the show have
heard quite a lot but uh it plays into
this especially with that iran quote
blogs realized that rage was getting the
most shares yes
so what they started doing was started
saying racism racism sexism racism then
they realized combining them got them
even more shares
you had kids who were 10 years old in
2008 they they're not very politically
active they go on facebook and they see
nothing but police brutality nothing but
posts about evil racism of america and
they've been living in that their entire
adult lives now it's no surprise they
believe all this woke insanity they
believe all this psychotic garbage
because it's been their entire life of
people just posting manipulative content
so to go to that quote those absurdities
have become the slogans of these young
people who are now in their 20s and
voting in i love it
we actually have some of these left to
sit here and tell us joe biden is the
right path towards avoiding corruption
and i'm like you don't know anything
about about the obama administration at
all do you no the national defense
authorization act indefinite detention
provisions how about biden inc putting
his brother in charge of iraqi
construction also in the family is
making millions of dollars the barisma
deals the investigations
all china oh flying on the plane i mean
come on i said this before i'll say it
again and then we'll segue to what i
wanted to talk about before i got
derailed if the republicans win the
house back they should impeach joe biden
on all of the evidence pertaining but
they won't do that of course they will
they will not do that be because they
believe that we're gentlemanly we're
above that
because this is a dog fight this this is
beyond a knife fight and you know i had
a dear friend of mine a marine retired
first time by name jim reifinger he said
if you ever find yourself in a fair
fight it's all because your tactics suck
and and we continue to want to have this
this fair fight we continue to want to
there's a great scene uh from officers
and gentlemen when david caruso is
standing there in front of louis gossett
jr and they're going to start doing the
training on hand-to-hand combat and he's
going to use david caruso the cadet as
his example and you know dave gruso well
this cadet knows by regulation uh gerald
sergeant you're not allowed to strike me
or anything like
really
and lou gossip puts it down into a choke
hole yeah and that's what republicans
are republicans stand there and if you
read solomon's rules for radicals you
know one of the rules are to constrain
your enemy
into their own principles and values and
and so that comes back to what is
happening at the border you have a
federal government that has completely
abdicated its constitutional duty to
protect the sovereignty of the state of
texas and the united states of america
and we're sitting around talking about
well we really can't do anything about
it because we don't have the ability of
the state the constitution says that you
can protect yourself when the federal
government abdicates their duty this is
interesting because the way you're
describing it it sounds very much like
the old trope of the revolutionary war
the crown was very much looking for a
regimented battle on the uh you know on
the on the standard we didn't play that
way we we didn't play and you know last
it's f i was watching last last the
mohicans that's why i was loving it
i was loving your little uh flatlock
pistol and and you're right i mean you
know we were the original gorilla
warriors here in north america we wanted
to win we want to win thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you